you
please welcome Adam Sandler and Academy
Award winner Catherine zeta-jones
all right okay I guess there's uh some
kind of mixer so uh I'm gonna have to do
this myself I don't know I can help you
with the lines okay all right Catherine
zeta-jones everybody okay hey will do
what's written okay Catherine may I just
say your dress looks incredibly sexy
tonight why thank you Adam it's Versace
well with you in it it should be called
BER sexy as a little girl growing up in
Wales
I saw many British TV series adapted
into major works of art a cat-cat Zeta
those high heels you're wearing our
major works of art they should be
hanging in a museum the Museum of
sexiness
okay listen Adam no more funny business
or you're liable to get a spanking
sign me up mrs. Douglas
you know what you're on your own now
okay all right thank you rock I love you
okay a screenplay is either an original
work or an adaption of some other
material both are incredibly challenging
the writers the Oscar for the Best
Screenplay adapted from another source
will go to one of these nominees Richard
Linklater Julie Delpy Ethan Hawke and
Kim Cuisine her before sunset based on
characters created by Richard Linklater
and Kim Cruzan for the film before
sunrise David McGee for Finding
Neverland based on the play the man who
was Peter Pan by Alan Neve Paul Haggis
for Million Dollar Baby based on stories
from rope burns by FX tool Jose Rivera
for the motorcycle diaries based on the
book noticed de viaje iron esto Guevara
and con el che for America latina by
Alberto granado's Alexander Payne and
Jim Taylor for sideways based on the
novel sideways by Rex picket right and
the Oscar goes to Alexander Payne and
Jim Taylor for sideways
this is the first Academy Award for
Alexander Payne and Jim Taylor Alexander
Payne is also nominated tonight for
directing sideways hi good evening uh we
thank the Academy we salute our fellow
nominees and we thank Rex picket on
whose novel the screenplay was based and
our wonderful producer Michael London
Jim we've been lucky enough to be
writing partners for 15 years and and
since the beginning we've had a great
pair of agents David Lubliner
and David Lauder and more recently a
great pair of wives the stunning and
talented Tamra Jenkins equally stunning
and talented Sandro and my mother taught
me to write and she died before she
could see any of this so this is for you
mom also real quick we love Fox
Searchlight for letting us make a film
with complete creative freedom and last
but not least very quickly and I'm going
to wrap up I want to share my side of
this award with the cast and crew of the
film because we had a lot of fun see you
later